أنا نوعًا ما محاصر تحت الحافة
وهو ليس السيناريو الأفضل دائمًا
لأنك لا تستطيع الخروج من
الطريق وإخراج نفسك من الموقف
إذا أصبح الوضع مشبوهًا
[موسيقى]
عندما تقوم بالصيد بالرمح  تحتاج أسماك القرش
من حولك دائمًا إلى طريق هروب
للخروج وأشياء من هذا القبيل،
وهناك مناسبة واحدة جعلت
نفسي محاصرًا تحت حافة ولم
يكن الوضع مثاليًا، حيث
لا تريد أسماك القرش بأي حال من الأحوال أن تؤذيني على الإطلاق  إنهم
يقومون فقط بالمهمة المتمثلة في الحصول على
السمكة المصابة، لذلك كان
موقفًا محرجًا بعض الشيء والذي تعلمته منه أنني
لا أضع نفسك أبدًا تحت
الحافة في مشكلة الفضاء الخاصة بك
من حيث المخاطر التي قد تكون عالقة تحت
الحافة، من الواضح أنك تستطيع ذلك'  لا أخرج،
وبالتالي إذا جاءت سمكة قرش لمحاولة الحصول على
الأسماك، فإن أسماك القرش ليست جيدة جدًا في
الرجوع إلى الخلف، ولا توجد طريقة حقًا
يريدون بها إيذائي عمدًا
ولكن قد يؤدي ذلك إلى حادث بسيط
أو محاولة حادة للهروب  لذا فإن أسماك القرش
ليس لديها نوايا خبيثة تجاهي،
فهي تريد السمكة فقط وهذه
مسؤولية القرش هي الحصول على تلك
السمكة وهذا ما يحاولون فعله، فهم
لا يحاولون إيذائي،
والغوص مع أسماك القرش كل يوم،
وصيد أسماك الأسد بالرمح كل يوم  هو
يوم تعليمي، حيث تنظر دائمًا إلى
سلوك سمكة القرش،
وتتكيف دائمًا مع سلوكك الخاص،
وتتعلم فقط كل يوم، ولا يمكنك أن
تكتفي أبدًا بأمجادك، ولا يمكنك أن
تعتقد أبدًا أنك خبير  لأن
الأشياء يمكن أن تحدث في لمح البصر، لذا
لا تموت وحدك أبدًا ولا
تضع نفسك أبدًا تحت حافة كهذه
وتضع نفسك في موقف محفوف بالمخاطر، لذا
السلامة أولاً طوال الوقت واستمر في
التعلم كل يوم
يضحك.